copy There is another copy
and it was yesterday it was yesterday
really the president when he gave the icon the
icon He said that Easter is with us, but
the fact is that we have Easter for 40
days Easter is celebrated for us and now it is
especially Easter week, so this is
simply wrong  they seized on this phrase and
immediately began to make hypotheses of what was not
there. This trip took place. You
see that now the president is increasingly
visiting new regions. Naturally, he
conducts checks of headquarters and
receives information on the spot.
Supreme
Commander-in-Chief and thus conducts
his work, there were many questions Why they did
n’t accompany
Shoigu
in the first place, of course, it
was expedient and the Supreme
Commander-in-Chief and the Minister of Defense of
the National Guard gathered in one place